you know I always get this question how
do I get all these vegetables in my body
in this video I'm going to create a
whole bunch of ideas on how to be
creative in getting all the vegetables
in your body and making them less boring
so number one is the kale shake as you
may already know on my website I'm
really big on kale why because it has
the most nutrition of any vegetable on
the planet has per cup it's like 35
thousand international units of vitamin
A a lot of potassium and so if you just
take kale and fruit blend it you can
drink your vegetables okay so that would
be number one then number two we can
actually cut down the salad now what I
have is I salad cutter and what you can
do is you can actually take the amount
of greens that you have now just so you
know I consumed a lot of greens you do
not have to do all these greens in one
sitting but this is just what I do so
I'll have the salad cutter you can get
at the store and you basically just cut
it down into very small little pieces so
you it makes it easier to break down and
digest and eat and then what I do is I
had a whole bunch of stuff on it and
then I actually had some salad dressing
I like the Newman's Own ranch dressing
because it's pretty good it's there's no
MSG there's no extra sugar it's very
easy I'll put the dressing on it and I'm
boom
good to go so cut down your salad make
it easier to consume alright number
three veggies with cheese so you can
have broccoli with melted cheese
cauliflower with melted cheese there's a
great restaurant in my area called the
melting pot and they it's incredible
they make this melted cheese and you dip
your vegetables and that's a very easy
and tasty way to get more greens or
vegetables in your diet now number four
steamed veggies there's a great recipe
that you would take spinach and you put
it on the on a pan in a stove and you
steam it and it cooks down into a
smaller amount I like to add organic
canned kidney beans warm those up
sometimes I put some tuna on it
and then you can put sea salt pepper and
garlic and it's incredible so that's
another thing that you can do that may
actually make it easy to consume your
greens number five we have cut Tomatoes
with basil if you have some really good
tasting tomatoes from the farmers market
or from the health food store that
actually tastes like tomatoes and you
cut those up and you add basil to it
fresh basil with ranch dressing that
makes a great kind of a salad but it's
different it don't have you don't have
the greens but it's a great way to get
your vegetables but you're actually
having tomatoes so that's another
favorite of mine all right number six
cut veggies with dip or hummus so you
have the traditional cucumber carrot
celery but you can have zucchini and
even mushrooms if you want and you just
dip them you could dip them into certain
dips that don't have msg or the ranch
dressing Newman's Own or hummus that's a
really no-brainer way to get more
vegetables without having to you know
like just eat them plain so make them
taste good now number seven zucchini
with pasta you could take zucchini I
have the recipe on that log shape it
down as noodles and you don't even have
to cook it actually you can have it raw
and put some pasta sauce on it or pesto
it's really really amazing some Parmesan
cheese I actually really enjoy this one
as well
number eight spaghetti squash with pasta
if you've never had spaghetti squash you
can get it at any grocery store you cut
it in half and you put in the oven for
about 40 minutes you bake it and it
comes out as noodles and it's great
because you could add some pasta sauce
make that could be your noodles and
instead of using the wheat pasta noodles
really delicious
it's another month another one of my
favorites number nine we have grilled
zucchini
you basically just grill it and before
you grill it you just put some olive oil
on it
sea salt and pepper and maybe some other
spices and it's quite delicious this is
another one of my favorite is another
way to just make vegetables taste good
all right number ten veggies and omelets
every time you make
in the morning to stuff it with
vegetables you can put mushrooms and
onions and tomatoes and whatever you'd
like
that's another favorite okay 11 baked
kale there's a big kale chip recipe you
can get pretty much anywhere on the
internet you just take your kale you
drizzle some olive oil and some sea salt
and you bake it and they're low heats
and it comes out this is your
alternative to your potato chip another
great way to make your vegetables taste
delicious
number 12 Green powders this would be
the barley greens or the wheatgrass
juice powders I have one called the
wheatgrass juice powder that's really
good because it's not just a wheatgrass
powder it's the wheatgrass juice powder
I mean one teaspoon is equivalent to
about four and a half pounds of
nutrients and vegetables so since the
purpose of vegetables is to give
nutrients this way you can have a very
small amount a little teaspoon in a
glass mix it up and drink it up and you
get a lot of nutrition without having to
eat four pounds of vegetables so that's
a really good idea Green powders of
course I want to mention my kale shake
my instant kale shake this is another
delicious way what I've done is I found
different ways to make taste good kale
taste good by taking powdered kale
mixing with chocolate or fruit or or
caramel flavoring and and putting a
protein called pea protein and it's
sweetened with the wreath with all and
xylitol and it's just the tad of stevia
and you just mix water or almond of
almond milk and blend it up or shake it
up and it's a great way to get your kale
in a shake so you you won't even taste
the kale in there but it has a good
amount of kale per serving okay number
fourteen your favorite veggies now what
does that mean it means that out of all
of that cheese what is your favorite
it's okay to consume large quantities of
just one vegetable if you don't like
vegetables like I had one guy he the
only vegetable that he liked was peace
and basically that's all he did he ate a
lot of peas every single day and he
bought the frozen pea
then slightly steamed him and he
consumed as he put those in omelets and
different things so you can also do that
as well
number 15 I created a recipe that
involved using cauliflower and
mozzarella cheese for the crust on a
pizza you can also do that that's
another way to get your kids to consume
cauliflower and you won't even taste it
it's in the crust it's quite delicious
very filling so you don't need much but
you could make a vegetarian pizza number
16
you could have vegetable soup I suggest
make your own put a lot of vegetables in
it you can put kale and beans and all
sorts of things a bean soup and that's
another no-brainer to get some more
vegetables because normally when you
have warmed soup it's it's better it's
very easy to consume that during the
winter because it goes down nicely
versus all the cold vegetables that you
would eat now number 17 in the last one
vegetable juice now I'm not recommending
the v8 because really those that's
pasteurized and when you heat all these
vegetables too much you kill it so as
you notice none of these involve
overcooking the vegetables like you
would get at the restaurant at the
all-you-can-eat buffets so this one is
involving the juicing of the vegetables
so I normally recommend I don't
recommend juicing but if you have this
with maybe just a little bit of carrot
to add a little bit of sweetness not too
much because it could spike your sugar
it's good to get some nutrition you can
do occasionally but you want to take
these green vegetables and you can juice
them and at least get the nutrition from
that but ideally it's better to blend
your vegetables so that's your summary
of how to get more vegetables in your
body and make them taste a little bit
more interesting